hey what's up man I'm Dalton pleasure so
we have Soulcalibur six in the building
tell me about this edition of Soul
Calibur latest edition
all right soul calibur six you know it's
the latest and greatest interation of
Soul Calibur it's running on unreal
unreal engine 4 we're playing a we're
playing on PC here at 4k yeah the game
looks fantastic you know one of the
first things you'll realize about the
game is the game it's really fast
you know you definitely wanted to take
that experience that people like really
remember from Soul Calibur to Soul
Calibur free bring that speed back one
thing you also probably probably
recognize is the characters are back to
their the young self so where this game
takes place around the events of the
original Soul Calibur game so you're
going to learn a lot more kind of
information around that time period a
lot more of the back stories about your
favorite characters you know right now
you got victory gave us a BTS it's a
classic showdown yeah maybe you know
some of the some of the awesome
mechanics that you know from Soul
Calibur back like Guardian pack and then
we've got some really some new mechanics
which I'll show you right here once
called a reversal edge
I'm trying to get it off so a lot of
reversal edges is you hold down the
right bumper and it creates a armored
attack so I actually will get absorbed
one attack yeah exactly so then it
starts to this kind of rock paper
scissor mechanic where each player gets
to pick up a movement you can see here
on the controller card it'll show you
how it works
it's a kicker of mail and you can also
dodge but one really interesting thing
about it is actually charges your meter
as well so it's got a it's kind of three
different mechanics there it's a good
way to kind of least at the battle it's
a an awesome way to kind of create a
cinematic moment and kind of you know
turn the tide of the battle yeah a lot
of great unreal for particle effects
like fantastic lighting you know the
team's been working really hard to get
that kind of awesome cinematic
experience so so right there I was just
doing that that's the critical edge so
you know each each player has a critical
edge which you know starts a really
awesome cinematic attack that that burns
your meter you can also do what's called
the sole charge with right trigger and
forward and that will actually put you
into a kind of a souped up state where
I'll do a higher damage output so so
he's gonna do his ready to go edge there
between jobs
[Music]
well I mean Imogen
yeah it's been that's it so you know you
know we we've been doing a lot of games
on unreal for you know so you know we're
really excited so caliber six we'll have
X will be X plus one X in there okay
we haven't revealed that information the
added but stay tuned and we'll have more
information about kind of you know gifts
pro and Xbox one X so open then we
really hope yeah probably
obviously this PC version right now it
looks yeah
[Music]
so just stay tuned to our social
channels of Soul Calibur Facebook page
and Twitter and we'll have more
information you know we've been mostly
focusing on the character reveals right
now so we've revealed nine characters
already and we just most recently
revealed Geralt from the winter so you
know we thought he was a perfect fit you
know it's he also comes from kind of a
medieval game yeah he's got his
signature steel and silver swords and
you know that the devs have done a lot
of work to really balance him and put
him into the game and make sure he fits
really well with the overall gameplay
mechanic game the phenomenal we've been
ready for that release any any window
just yeah we're still 2018 stay tuned as
I said we'll have more information on
the release timing hormones more
character so just stay tuned so callable
you obviously have to spectacular we
cannot wait thank you so much no problem
thank you so much